over the past two years at least so it's
really been building for a longer time
the social media Giants
have clamped down on conservative speech
it hasn't been an even clamping down on
speech it's been
almost entirely focused on the right
now what does that mean in a country
that's supposedly a self-government
where the way that we pass laws and
govern ourselves is by persuading one
another of arguments if you control
speech you control the whole culture
this is the point of my book speechless
controlling words controlling wines
number one National bestseller it makes
a great Christmas present just pointing
that out before Black Friday so
that has been the situation on the
ground and then in walks
Elon Musk and Elon Musk comes in and he
buys Twitter and at first it seems like
a joke and a meme and for a while it
looked like he didn't want to buy
Twitter but then a judge sort of forced
him to buy Twitter and so anyway he
spends 44 billion dollars and he is
having a whole lot of fun and there have
been all of these debates over do you
let people on do you not let people on
do you have free speech do you not have
free speech I got into a little spat
with Sam Harris you know Sam Harris made
a splash as one of these
atheists 15 years ago he was one of the
four new atheists which was much more a
publishing Trend than a than an
intellectual movement but anyway that's
where he became somewhat famous and he
said it's really dangerous you can't
have people like Donald Trump or whoever
on Twitter it's really dangerous for
these people to spread misinformation
can you imagine how dangerous it is and
I and I responded to him and I said Sam
you know you're right
Elon should not tolerate the New York
Times or the Washington Post remaining
on this platform I mean that when I
think of the dangerous lies that they
spread those guys need to be axed
immediately and Sam responded with some
sort of glib you know oh yeah you really
thought about this haven't you Michael
which by the way I have uh and then I
referenced my number one National
best-selling book speechless which I
recommend you get for Black Friday so
the the point here I think though is
that
the New York Times And The Washington
Post
are responsible for for a great deal
more evil because of their dishonest
journalism
then Donald Trump is
what do they accuse Donald Trump of
doing
Donald Trump LED an Insurrection he
didn't really do that well he led those
people to go to the Capitol well he sort
of a little bit he did that though he
said to be peaceful and people died yeah
the only person who died in the
political violence of that day was a
trump supporter named Ashley Babbitt who
was murdered by a trigger happy cop
that's it
and then I think if you really want to
add to the numbers you I think a couple
of people died of natural causes that
day there were a lot of people there and
people had heart attacks and stuff like
that but no one died no cops were
murdered none of that that was all
completely made up okay
furthermore when you look at the New
York Times as advocacy of certain Wars
you know you can look at the New York
Times spreading propaganda and nonsense
to justify some of our recent Wars you
think about the people who died as a
result of that
you think about the the nonsense spread
by The Washington Post and the New York
Times with regard to the Russia hoax
which allowed or gave cover to the
government to spy on a rival
presidential campaign and then
undermined a duly elected president
goodness sakes that's a that's a big
problem I mean I was joking a little bit
with Sam Harris but I'm pretty serious
there's a strong argument to be made
that the New York Times And The
Washington Post should not be permitted
on Twitter because their their
dishonesty has led to really awful
outcomes it's led to death in some cases
okay and so uh Elon Musk is taking a
middle ground here he is not a free
speech absolutist and he's getting a lot
of flack from the right about this but I
don't think he should I think this is
actually extremely based
I you know I
I know this puts me on the outs with
some of the right wing though I think
actually the conservatives are coming
much more over to my point of view here
but there's nothing conservative about
Free Speech absolutism
there's nothing conservative about
having a bunch of obscenity and porn and
direct threats all over social media and
in the Public Square that's not
conservative that's radical and leftist
okay and it was the libs Who tricked
conservatives into believing that
nonsense okay and so Elon Musk comes out
he says new Twitter policy is freedom of
speech but not freedom of reach negative
hate tweets will be Max debusted and
demonetized so no ads or other Revenue
to Twitter
you won't find the Tweet unless you
specifically seek it out which is no
different from the rest of the internet
Kathy Griffin Jordan Peterson and the
Babylon B have been reinstated Trump
decision has not been made yet although
you'll see what comes later
Alex Jones is not allowed on Twitter now
I don't agree with all of those
decisions I think Alex Jones should be
on Twitter Kathy Griffin I don't mind if
she's not on Twitter I'm glad that
eventually Trump did come back on
spoiler alert but
the principle that Elon is describing
here is totally right
okay and and you're hearing the right
say well new boss same as the old boss
this is no different from what the left
is doing
it is different it is different
when conservatives
allow good and true and beautiful things
to be
present in the Public Square and
discourage
ugly and false and evil things in the
Public Square
that is not the same
as when the left
exalts ugliness and wickedness and
falsehood
and suppresses goodness truth and Beauty
it's not the same yes both involve
having standards both involve having
Norms both involve having taboos both
involve limiting speech
but that procedural similarity does not
mean that they are substantively the
same thing
to to do good and avoid evil is not the
same thing as to do evil and avoid good
okay and conservatives used to
understand this conservatives used to be
the group of norms and standards and
having higher ideals and being polite
and understanding chivalry chivalry is a
is a code of speech and behavior that
censors certain things okay being a
gentleman involves censoring certain
things and limiting what can be said and
done and promoting other things that are
said and done okay but
that's all regimes okay that's all
states that's all forms of speech there
are always limits and so I don't think
we should knock Elon for having
standards and Norms I think that
we should help to tweak his standards
enormous but his standards and Norms are
a hell of a lot better than Vijaya Gotti
was that her name the the Twitter
apparatchee who banned Trump the first
time and his and elon's are a hell of a
lot better than Jack dorsey's and I
think he should be encouraged in that
the libs are freaking out CBS news said
they were going to stop tweeting out of
an abundance of caution
caution about what well with the
changing standards at Twitter we're
going to stop tweeting out of an
abundance of caution what do you think
is going to happen
and then by the way this is the best
part 48 hours later CBS starts tweeting
again okay but we're monitoring the
situation they said but but we're going
to be back on Twitter okay that's great
if they're freaking out all right Trump
is back this and the way Elon did it was
brilliant he threw up a poll he said
should Trump go back on
most people said yes then all of a
sudden it started to turn there were
tens of millions of votes in this poll
you could tell there were some maybe
some political forces here that were
trying to keep Trump off of Twitter but
Elon said vox populi Vox day the voice
of the people is the voice of God
which is a principle I don't exactly
agree with but nevertheless it gave him
a way of bringing Trump back to Twitter
without taking all of the responsibility
for it's really important for the
political order when that Twitter lawyer
lady booted Trump off of Twitter that
was a revolution in America's political
order that was saying that some
billionaire leftists in Silicon Valley
and their Min their minions can
sensor can ostracize the duly elected
sitting president of the United States
so it's a very important restoration of
America's political order this is not
just a minor funny little meme thing oh
there it goes Elon
he put Trump back this is actually a
major restoration of America's political
order the question is Will trump
actually come back on and use the
account
I hope he does when they restated
reinstated Trump's account he had zero
followers now he's up to like 10
bazillion he's got way more followers
than Joe Biden he's obviously very
popular despite what the lying press
wants to tell you despite the constant
negative Fresco FeFe is what Trump
proved to us and I think he should come
back on the trouble for Trump is he's
he's made a deal with truth social
that that will be his social media
platform but no one looks at truth
social the only reason anyone checks
Druid social is to see what Trump has to
say which is
probably a sizable number of people but
it's not actually being used as a social
network if Trump goes back onto Twitter
he will have so much more reach he will
dominate the conversation again the guy
is now declared candidate for president
so I hope he figures out some way to
thread the needle but I want Trump back
on Twitter good on Elon for doing it
good on Elon for having standards too
the guy is doing almost everything right
and the libs are so freaking out I don't
know about you I feel like I am living
in 2015 again I am having deja vu all
over again for some of our younger
listeners they might not even remember
2015 all that well I mean it's amazing
to think right now that's seven years
ago now it's a in within a month and a
half it's going to be eight years ago
that was a long time ago and it's it's
just makes me think that people
don't learn anything because all of the
same stupid arguments from all from
exactly the same people we are hearing
again Trot it out as though it is fresh
and new marks and angles you know talk
about calling out the system talking
about breaking up regular political
platitudes and attitudes I'll give marks
and Engels some credit here history
repeats itself first as tragedy then as
fars now today's music Monday
and I am told by my producers that were
listening to rap music today
great
the rest of the show continues now you
do not want to miss it if you're not a
member click the link in the description
and join us
[Music]
[Music]